maybe an example you could share where
that happened where game was like kind
of kind of give you an earful and some
of some of the [ __ ] you might have said
um
what the [ __ ] was i was doing something
on social media
oh nipsy
i was gonna say it was it had to have
been the nipsy thing you'd think right
it was nessie but he understood
what i was saying
to be to be clear what you said was
nipsey's not a legend nippy's not a
legend in music in music yeah not in the
streets you know
the streets he from will dictate and
determine that you know what i'm saying
pretty soon by the way
he died i think you were in the club and
you had the dj play his music i remember
dj i was in chicago yeah i remember i
hadn't played some west coast [ __ ] like
you know
you know i did that i stopped the whole
club we was in chicago and then me and
blueface
and did and just so you know blueface
neighborhood and they neighborhood don't
get along
you know that could have caused a rift
but i'm in the middle of a blue-faced
club host and i stopped the whole club
and you know just
you know a moment of silence for nipping
and let's play his music and then we
went on about our night but it got to a
point to where
um
game definitely pulled up on me
what do you say he said bro i understand
everything you said you got your point
across can you please just not say it no
more
i tell you and i'm born i'm going on
and he rolled out you know what i'm
saying so when that happened
i remember me and head
talking like damn there's some [ __ ]
like we love you wack right but i'm like
there's just some [ __ ] like you could
have kept to yourself
and i think you know and you right but i
think in my life in my world
as fake as all this [ __ ] is
i like to keep it as real as i can
like even if you feel that way right and
i'm not saying i share your opinion
about the nips and [ __ ] yeah but even if
you feel that way and and not to say you
know the way you laid out your argument
about like ice cubes snoop dre all these
yeah
why even put it out there
well they asked me a question
and i think the problem with me is i
don't know how to run
fair enough i'm gonna keep it real
i think if a person asks me a question
and i have a
logical answer
and i say well
why
this answer
them people over there ain't gonna like
i'm gonna say well why are they not
gonna like it am i telling the lie
am i am i disrespecting anybody or is it
i shouldn't say it because of how they
go they telling me i just think like any
time someone is no different than when i
come into holding tanks
back then in them days
hey cause they cuz they cuz they cuz
they cuz they cuz they cuz where you
from nine deep [ __ ] this pierrot
some people that would have said
nowhere
i couldn't run whatever came with that
it came with that and i think that's
really what my problem is and i know how
to fix the problem i'm fixing the
problem